- Yikes.
- That was a bit of a, a bomb.
This prop on this note that I'm.
- I'm gonna cry.
(upbeat music)
Let's see, this one's real folded.
Oh, this one's long.
Oh, they said, what if you
get a sad one and I sure did.
I kept my dad's alcoholism
a secret for years
and he used to tell me how he
never wanted a child like me
and how I would never find love.
Flash forward a few years
and my first boyfriend said
I would never find love either.
So now I don't feel worthy
of love and won't date
because I feel too broken.
I'm gonna cry.
They know my friends who
were with me know that I cry
like, at everything, I cry when I talk,
I cry when other people cry.
So like that was so sad, I hope
that that person finds love
and realizes that they're worthy of it.
Even if it's through like friendships,
that's, what's been most important to me
is finding like friends who
appreciate all the sides of me.
So I can only hope that for that person.
And if I knew them, I would
give them all the love
that I could.
Damn, my turn,
I was gonna write something funny,
I'm like, okay.
Oh, so stupid, whoever reads this,
I hope they get a good laugh out of it.
- I'm not always as brave as I may seem.
I feel that, the moment I
read it I was like, yeah,
me too.
- I wish I was divorced.
My wife has made me feel
trapped for six years.
- I didn't know I was
pregnant until I miscarried.
I feel guilty because I
may have had something
to do with it.
The night before I found out I was drunk.
- I've stabbed the person
three times without any remorse
and I wonder if that makes me inhumane.
I wanted a happy one.
- I slept with my teacher and he still
didn't give me a good grade.
I don't know what to say.
- I can't tell if I
should go after the hot,
hot boy or my best friend who I can see
something stronger happen.
Okay, that is horribly relevant to mine.
Like I always like get
friends owned by people.
Yeah, but I'm also like the hot girl,
you know what I mean?
(laughing)
I think you gotta go for
the long lasting one,
you ought to go for the
best friend, not the boy
who's hawt exclamation point,
HAWT exclamation point.
So I, or maybe like go
for the hot boy first
and then I was gonna say,
don't tell the friend that's
really bad, don't do that, no.
Moral compass go for the friend.
- My parents don't know that I got an STD
and that I'm no longer virgin.
I can really relate with this
person and not the STD part,
but just the not having
that bond with the parents,
being able to talk to
them about certain things.
I totally understand how this person feels
and where they're coming from
and missing that connection
with their parents.
I think it's something special
that everybody should have
but, not everybody does.
- I feel like I can relate to this.
Okay, this person's secret is I feel like
I'm never satisfied in
life and always want more.
I guess, 'cause like I have a
really hard like self critic,
so I'm always like, I want
more, like I want to be the best
and I feel like I may never
like reach that stuff.
So I guess also, I guess
that could be my secret too,
whereas I can relate to this person.
- I was sexually assaulted
when I was 14 years old
and I've never been able to
talk to a boy with confidence
and trust ever again.
I was assaulted at a younger age too
and it's a hard burden to
carry because sometimes
you don't know if you're
carrying it at all
and it just develop into your personality,
loss of trust of the people around you
and fear of the unknown.
So, I understand it.
Secrets hold a lot of weight
and when you can focus and
distract yourself from the weight
you're carrying, you can,
personally, I can go about my day,
but when I have to confront
secrets that I'm holding,
I lose my resilience enough
to come close to breaking down
or crying.
And since I'm in public,
I'm trying to contain myself
a little bit, but, it's late in the day
and I'm kinda a little bit
more relaxed than I usually am.
So, I'm emotional enough
to just like maybe my eyes
are getting watery.
So I just can't wait to go
back to ignoring the secret.
- Sometimes I fall into a
complete spiral to a point
where I'll never get out at times.
Huh, it's way deeper than
I thought it would be.
I guess for the person that wrote this,
if you ever like at the bottom,
the only way is up, right?
There's no other way.
- I'm scared that the real me
is someone who is not as good
as I want to be, meaning I
get jealous and manipulate.
- I still have feelings for my ex.
- I wish I never gotten married.
- It says, I need to eat more vegetables.
- I like Owen, I don't know who Owen is,
but you are very lucky.
- All right, so the secret is I ruined
my cousin's bridesmaid
dress before the wedding
and never told her.
- One time I accidentally peed my pants
in the freezer at work.
I really want like a follow
up as to what happened
and if anybody found out.
- I lick my own pack,
I think that's awesome.
- I don't love my boyfriend anymore
and I don't know how to tell him.
I think to leave him a
note and then ghost him.
- On Halloween of 2019 while
dressed in full cowgirl attire,
I peed in between two
Subway cars because my train
was stuck and then I peed on
the steps of the train station.
Oops, LOL, I dunno, I
probably would've done
the same thing honestly.
- My boyfriend cheated
on me with a married man.
Ooh, hold on, really?
My boyfriend cheated on me
with a married man, that's T.
- I've been dating a
boy for four years now,
I've found out recently that I'm lesbian,
I don't know how to tell him.
Whoever you are that you just found out,
I think you should just
come out and tell him.
- All right guys, I'm gonna read one.
It's kinda dead out here,
no one's stopping, so.
And no, I did not put my secret here,
so don't try to guess.
Okay, it says, I worry about
whether or not my brother
is capable of harming his
significant other out of rage.
So the first thing I
thought after I read this
was that I felt bad for whoever
wrote it 'cause it makes me
feel like they probably
have some experience
with their brother being
harmful towards them,
which is why they have this fear.
So I hope that's not true,
I hope they've never
experienced anything like that,
but it's really sad because
it seems like that's the case.
So, sending lots of love to them.
- I am an insult and it's
not that I'm bitter or mean,
but it's because I see the
big picture modern women
are entitled and men are
the ones who have to take
the brunt, like gain
their trust, for example.
I did a figure out, I think
this person has been hurt
if they think like that,
especially that like towards all women,
because I know a lot of women
who are great and amazing.
- I wish I could let myself
trust the people I love more.
Yeah, I relate to that honestly.
I was honestly gonna put
the same thing on there too.
- The failure of relationships
and my family have caused me
to question if it will ever
be possible for me to be loved
by someone else.
- My parents' marriage is
the reason I don't want
to get married.
- Everything I do is
overcompensate for validation,
it's about how I look.
I think the best thing I would
give someone, like the person
who wrote this is just to
spend more time with themselves
and just be comfortable with who they are
and once you have that, like
comfort and love for yourself,
you don't really start to
seek for that validation.
How I did it, like,
what I think is the best
is just to go out like
on dates with yourself,
or like treat yourself like
after you get your paycheck,
go get something that you really wanted
and just show that love that
you seek for from others,
like give it to yourself
and don't wait for it.
So I think that's what
everybody should be doing.
And then you start to attract the energy
that you become instead of
chasing it and seeking for it.
- All right, guys it's
getting kind of late
and I'm gonna go home soon.
So I thought I'd read the
remaining secrets in this bowl.
All right, first secret,
I'm annoyingly in love
with my best friend,
but can never do anything about it, damn.
You should call them up
and ask them on a date
and it's that easy.
I'm just kidding, I
know it's not that easy.
All right, next one,
I've told my alcoholic
dad that I've forgiven him
for all the pain he has
caused me, I haven't
and I'm not sure I ever will.
Looks like there's two of us
who have forgiveness problems,
whether you do ever forgive
them or if you don't,
I hope that the pain goes away,
yeah, thanks for sharing this.
All right guys, that's all
the secrets in the bowl,
thanks for watching this
episode, I know it was new,
I hope you enjoyed it.
And yeah, it's my birthday
at the end of this month
and I don't know why this
birthday has been feeling
a certain type of way and
it's like in a good way.
Best way I can describe the
way this birthday's making me
feel is that it's the way
I thought right before
my birthday, right before
I started this channel,
it's making me want to
try a lot of new things,
which means you'll be
seeing a lot of new content
on my channel, but also still
the old content as well,
don't worry, I'll keep
sharing those, but you'll see,
I have some things planned
and it's gonna start showing.
So, yeah, I hope you stay tuned,
I hope you enjoy.
Thank you guys for everything,
I love you all and I'll see you next week.
(upbeat music)